hey hey welcome back everyone our
friends over at my book you thought it
was time for us to take a little break
from all that is going on
so i have invited my very best friend
austere religious scholar michael moles
to play a little game
two truths one lie the game is simple
one person lists off three things about
themselves two of them
are the god's honest truth one is a
bald-faced lie
the other person must determine which is
the lie whomever guesses the most lies
is the winner you know ben i'm very
honored to get this invitation i'm very
excited for it
it's going to be a difficult game i
actually think that i'm at a
disadvantage here because like abe
lincoln i i have never told a lie but
i'm going to do my best
and i was thinking since you know since
we're we're here i
i don't get to see you anymore in the
studio we're thousands of miles apart
i figured maybe we make it interesting
we add a little wager you know
i still have some cash left over from uh
2016. so i was thinking i don't know
maybe like a
like a friendly bed maybe 100 dollars
something yeah let's do this thing
let me just tell you let me just tell
you when i walked into the bank this
morning and i got myself
100 ones for this either they thought
that i was
headed to the world's worst strip club
or
i was about to do an enormous amount of
good for the homeless people all around
south florida
by driving off of every off ramp and
just handing every single person to one
you might have been working on a really
important story about hunter biden you
might have just been getting ready to do
all your research all around either way
though i'm excited
alrighty here we go which of the
following statements
is the lie i once caught a foul ball at
a baseball game
i was called on stage at a vegas magic
show
i once won a small lottery prize
i'm gonna say
you you never
were called on stage at a vegas magic
show that's the lie
wrong i was indeed called on stage at a
vegas magic show
actually it's a fantastic story it
actually is a really good story
like they called me on stage and uh it
was they lined me up
it was the magician it was lance burton
award-winning magician
and he was standing next to a girl who's
staying next to me and he took out his
top hat
and he started pulling eggs out of the
hat and he would hand them to her and
she was supposed to hand them to me and
i would run out of hands and drop the
eggs and that was the joke right there's
only one problem i was wearing the
world's baggiest sweatpants that day
and so he handed her the eggs she handed
me the eggs i started stuffing the eggs
in my pockets he actually ran out of
eggs
i said joke's on you lance burton never
calls you
magician destroyed correct i was
decision destroyed with sweatpants and
logic
correct i was 12 at the time and that's
when the legacy began
so which was the lie so the lie was that
uh i i've never won a small lottery
prize
wow not even a scratcher no nothing i
don't participate in the lottery
lottery's for suckers
no you're right it's just whenever
people give me scratchers i always say
you're
it's the worst gift for a conservative
because you're giving me the ability to
pay extra taxes i don't i don't like it
very much
okay which of these following statements
is a lie
i speak portuguese i attended george
soros's wedding
i've never read war and peace
okay um i feel like i would have heard
if you'd attended soros's wedding
so i'll say you attended soros's wedding
is the lie
i attended george soros's wedding what i
did
i did this is one of my favorite stories
i
so you know back in my wayward youth for
a couple years after college i was a
professional actor
it was like working all these terrible
acting jobs in new york you know plays
and
and tv shows and stuff like that so i
get called out and audition for a live
theater event and uh show up you know go
to take any audition i can get
and they say okay what languages do you
speak so say i speak this language that
language whatever
and i jokingly added i said and
esperanto i said that probably won't
matter though and they said no it
doesn't matter
the client speaks esperanto i said it's
george soros they said how'd you know
that i was like cause they're like four
people that speak esperanto one of them
is george soros he's the only one with
money
and so i went they were hiring actors to
be fake sommelier
at the wedding because they wanted to
discriminate based on looks and how you
talk and everything
so i go and it's i'm there i'm pouring
wine for christine lagarde head of the
imf
pelosi is there bono is there kofi annan
is there
i was in the heart of it and it did
actually make me think that this whole
idea of the conspiracy theories and all
that
is not that great because if they had
even just googled me they would have
found out that i am definitely a
conservative republican
but instead they just let me write in i
was right there in the heart of it all
you could have unmasked everything
everything i know
i mean if you just wandered into the
wrong bedroom all of this could have
been stopped
yeah i know it's i if only i had been a
little quicker on my feet at soros as
well i'll have to wait for his next
wedding so which one is the lie
the lie is oh i don't speak portuguese
okay that was that was next
i've also never read war and peace uh
yeah i i figured there was a significant
possibility you'd not read war and peace
considering you wrote a book with no
words in it but anyway
continue alrighty my turn
which of the following statements is a
lie i have a picture with kiefer
sutherland
i have a picture with andrew breitbart i
have a picture with ozzy guillen okay
well you obviously have a
a picture with breitbart i don't even
know who the last guy is
and i i wouldn't be surprised if you
have a photo with kiefer sutherland when
you guys were out like solving crimes
and stuff together
so i'm gonna go with the third one the
third one's the lie no the lie is that i
have a picture with andrew breitbart
unbelievably enough i have no picture
with andrew breitbart it's one of the
great regrets of my life
because you know when you're serious
yeah when you're friends with people
like you
really don't often take pictures with
them it's actually something that i've
made a point of doing since andrew
died i remember that jeremy and i
basically had no pictures together and
then we were at some event maybe
five six years ago and i was like dude
we have no pictures together if you get
hit by a truck tomorrow
nobody's ever gonna know that we're
business partners and so we should
really like grab a picture so now i make
a point of trying to get pictures with
friends but yeah i mean i worked with
andrew i knew andrew for
15 years and there's not a single
picture of us together
and i'm really pissed about it because
he like threw me a book party when one
of my books came out about tv he was
like the guy behind it yeah and i know
that there are pictures taken at that
event and none of them have ever
surfaced so it's it's really a point of
high irritation for me it's really sad
actually wow that's interesting that's
like that is actually good advice yeah
because that does happen when you're
around people all the time and
you don't you don't take pictures with
them well that's crazy which of the
following statements is a lie
hillary clinton is my cousin-in-law i
have
osgood schlatter's disease i love atlas
shrugged
i'm gonna go with i love atlas shrugged
i don't i actually don't think you love
atlas shrugged i mean you're you're a
catholic and you're a big government
catholic sometimes and uh and so yeah i
don't think that's right
yeah i like to i prefer the phrase um
imperialist catholic you know just like
a full-on
um no you're right i hate atlas shrugged
i hate it i used to like some of ein
rand's writing when i was a teenager
like the shorter books
but that damn book atlas i've tried to
read it like 15 times
and i always get to page 2028 and i just
like give up i'm like i'm not
you didn't even make it to the golf
speech okay you didn't even make it to
the i know i didn't even make it to
the recap of the entire book in another
80 pages yep
yeah that's right yeah what what is
oswald schlatter's disease
oh it's uh as good schlatter disease
thank you for your ableist language uh
it's when you've got a little bump on
your knee
uh there's a name for it it's called
osgood slaughter disease it's very tough
as a catholic by the way because you got
to kneel down a lot
uh but listen i bear my i bear my
injuries
and i i make it through despite this
oppressive culture wow
wow okay here we go which of the
following statements is the lie
i wanted to major in genetic science i
did once major in philosophy
and i did once major in english
which is a lie and they're all you
they're all you did want to
uh well one was i wanted to in one is i
and two are i did
so i wanted to major in genetic science
i did major in philosophy i did major in
english
i'm gonna say you the lie
is that you majored in english i don't
think you made your name that's right i
did not major in english ding ding
correct
didn't major in english yeah i knew more
than the professors i didn't need to
major in english
is that it's like excuse me guys i've
already written 15 books
okay i don't need to i don't need you to
teach me about the english language
okay which of the following statements
is a lie
i play the sitar i play chess
i voted for bob dole in 1996.
how old is knowles this is the question
about voting for bob dole in 96.
so how old are you nulls 30
30. okay fine so you're 38 is now 20 20.
so
[Laughter]
so that means that you would have had to
vote for bob dole in 1996
when you were six years old so i will go
with that being
the lie unless you committed voter fraud
which i wouldn't put past you
but i feel like committing voter fraud
at age six would still be would still be
kind of weird so i'll go with that one
i voted for bob dole in 1996. i did i
did i think i
it's hard to tell i mean what i did
certainly violated the law but
the reason is i was i was six years old
my mother was going to vote for clinton
i don't know why because she voted for
like ray she worked for reagan for a
while she
so like she was kind of a republican
kind of a democrat but in 96 i hated
clinton
because i don't know i'd seen like cnn
or something and i knew that he was a
draft dodger and i knew that
that dole was a war hero and that's all
i knew about the race
and i just loved dole and i begged my
mother a little six-year-old michael
parted hair i was like mom you have to
vote for dole
and she was like what the hell is what's
wrong with this kid and then
on election day i went to the polling
with her and she said you know what
michael
you're so into this come into the voting
booth with me came into the voting booth
and she let me go up and pick
dole and then pull the lever so this is
my admission that little six-year-old
michael committed voter fraud
now voter fraud is obviously very
mainstream but back then i like to think
i was a visionary
which of the following statements is the
lie i am a
good violinist i can play the piano i am
a world-class
whistler you are not a world-class
whistler there is no way that's true
no that that actually is true i'm a very
very wrestler i'm an ex
you're kidding me i'm an excellent i've
never heard your whistle oh yeah i have
a couple of
particularly very odd skills like like
liam neeson and taken but incredibly
useless and and not
useful in a hostile situation
i will find you uh and if so i can play
uh tunes on my cheeks
this is one of the things i can do so
for example a big
pick a tune we'll do we'll do name that
tune here how about uh zippity-doo-dah
okay well i don't know it's racist now
in it but here we go i know we're gonna
get canceled if we need to
here we go
yeah that's the thing that was so much
more impressive than i thought it was
going to be
right you thought it was just going to
be like the rhythm but it actually is
the tune i know it's pretty incredible
i i can do i can do mozart my i'm famous
for my uh for my queen of the night arya
which which that does happen wow that
where uh i have a lot of questions i
have a question
[Music]
that is so much more entertaining than
it has any right to be
like really wow yeah i mean
um listen some some pundits abuse
themselves
on zoom calls others hit themselves in
the face on zoom calls
that wow yeah i'm a very good i'm a very
good whistler
so uh that's very impressive but do you
know you don't play piano uh no
i can play the first few bars of the
moonlight sonata and that is about it
you can play your cheeks but you can't
play
piano that is wow i'm all right i lost
that one fair and square
which of the following statements is a
catholic lie
in vitro fertilization is permitted
within the catholic church so long as no
embryos are killed and one biological
parent remains in the child's life
saint genesis is the patron saint of
clowns movies actors
plumbers and torture victims the big
bang theory was developed by a belgian
catholic priest
named father george lemaitre
um
i'll i'll go with the second one
although i don't know maybe there's a
picture in the saints of plumbers
actually saint genesis is the patron
saint of clowns movies actors plumbers
and torture victims
so he's your parents and then i guess i
mean you're you're a clown and an actor
i mean like
we're there this is no joke when i when
i was like 12 years old or something
like that i
wore a little medal of saint genesis
around my neck i actually had there was
like
some debate over whether saint genesis
even lived but i did i
gotta love saint genesis no the lie was
ivf no ivf can't do it
never really no ivf at all i mean
there's a lot of uh
a lot of confusing statements coming out
of the vatican these days but the one
they still have not
backed down on is ivf interesting okay i
did not know that
alrighty michael i'm gonna continue with
this idiotic game but first
let's talk about the people who are
making all of this possible
it can be a lot of fun betting on sports
and politics actually
i did a bunch of prop bets for that last
presidential debate can't say i did
fantastically well but it is
betting season at my bookie as if you
weren't already way too into politics
right now with my bookie you can bet on
things like the winner of the
presidential election
even the day the loser will concede the
race which is kind of dark
they even had betting opportunities for
example on that presidential debate
so will joe biden call trump a racist
for example
i mean the answer obviously was yes
nothing makes an event more exciting
than putting some money on it makes it
fun with sports and election season in
full swing
now is the time to try your hand whether
you've been betting for years or you're
ready to play for the first time my
bookie is your go-to this season
with the biggest online selection of
bets and props my bookie has made it
simple to win and easy
to withdraw your care so for example i
bet on the color of the ties the
candidates we're going to wear i got
that one right
head on over to my bookie to create an
account just use the promo code shapiro
to claim your 100
deposit match all the way up to a
thousand bucks that means if you put in
they'll give you another hundred dollars
it's an easy way to jump start that
bankroll
nfl nba mlb everything else they've got
it all on tap it's never too late to get
started on your winning season only at
my bookie
alrighty let's get back into it which of
the following statements is the lie and
here's where i confess all my sins you
ready here we go
i have accidentally eaten chicken
parmesan i have accidentally eaten bacon
i have accidentally eaten cow brains hmm
there's no way you could accidentally
eat chicken parmesan because you would
see the cheese on it
there is a way you could accidentally
eat bacon if it were like in something
but we're kind of chopped up small
and i think i don't think you could eat
cow brains accidentally i've eaten cow
brains and i
so i'm going to say the lie
is i don't think you've accidentally
eaten chicken parmesan
i have accidentally eaten chicken
parmesan uh and it it was
by the way it was absolutely delicious
my goodness phenomenal yeah
just so good i used to make this pesto
chicken you take pesto you put on the
inside of the chicken and then you bread
it
with uh with like onion rings and it's
really really good
and i went to the kosher market and i
picked up a packet of pesto
what i neglected to check is that the
pesto was mixed with parmesan cheese
and so i cooked it and i started to eat
it and i said to my wife this is the
greatest chicken
i have ever made in my entire life this
is unbelievably good and she said
i don't think that that's kosher and i
was like oh
no yeah i did accidentally oh no yeah so
tell me that once i finish this
delicious chicken parmesan
juice yeah exactly the uh yeah i've
never accidentally eaten bacon
uh the uh as far as as far as cow brains
it's mainly because
i was a kid and who the hell knows what
what is it sweet bread
sweet breads right so when they they
said sweetbreads you think of yourself
okay like
what could it be like it can't be
anything bad and then it's like oh no
you're eating the prefrontal cortex of a
cow
that's terrifying yeah pretty good not
as good as chicken parmesan but it is
i can get into it sometimes well that's
i'm glad you had the experience of
chicken parmesan at some point you have
to accidentally try bacon because
isn't there there's a yiddish expression
which is if you're going to eat pork
eat it till your mouth drips or
something i can't do it in yiddish but
it's something like that i i've never
heard that one but okay
um okay which of the following is the
lie
i wear contacts i leaned into pitches in
little league
i directed opera in college
um you leaned into pitches in little
league
you know i leaned i couldn't hit that
ball for anything i was leading
almost every time no i just had to guess
they all feel so true
yeah no no context because i get afraid
with the thing in my eye so i can't do
it it's just blurry so you're just
driving at night it's all just a sea of
cuz i know you wear the rachel maddow
glasses so if you don't have the rachel
maddow glasses you're literally just
oper you're flying blind right now like
i could come over there and just smack
you in the head you'd have no idea which
direction i was coming from right now
i'd have no idea whatsoever i'm just
seeing a sort of reveal
some gauzy shapiro you should you should
have revealed you should never have
revealed this this is not going to
redown to your benefit
okay here we go which of the following
statements is the lie
i skipped third grade i skipped fourth
grade
i skipped ninth grade
you you did not skip
ninth grade it's it'd be you're more
likely to skip a grade when you're
younger so i'm gonna say you did not
skip ninth grade
uh i did skip ninth grade i did not skip
fourth grade so
you skipped third and ninth third and
ninth yeah
man that's of course you did of course
you did of course you skipped those two
grades that's fair fair enough you're
like the only guy ever who skipped a
high school grade
yep all right uh which of the following
is the lie
i once got into a car chase in arabia
i played drums in my high school band
i was once given my own float down fifth
avenue
for the columbus day parade
um god these are so bizarre um
i'll say the float in the columbus day
parade because that's yet to that's yet
to come you're gonna be the only person
in new york who still approves of
columbus day
so it'll the entire parade will just be
you in a float and it won't actually be
like a full float it'll actually be just
like a floatation device from a pool
and it's just you're walking down fifth
avenue
and we'll call it driving it away from
the mob that's coming to tauren feather
me i actually was given my own float in
the columbus day parade because no one
else would be on a float with you or
what
it was no it was just me and it was
because i had done a maki i translated a
play by machiavelli and it was like the
500th anniversary of a machiavelli
of the prince and so they the columbus
foundation found me and gave me this
float
and i felt like freaking mussolini
because they gave me this big float and
a microphone
and i was just sort of like speaking
spatting off whatever i wanted
the only two other people on the float
were these two gals that i like picked
up at the
start of the parade and i called them my
machiavets so that was true
so it's just you on the microphone going
blood alone greases the wheels of
history
[Applause]
it was great you know luckily it was an
italian so they didn't all understand it
but
yeah it was really quite a sight it's
amazing how cultured you are for such a
schmuck
all right anyway here we go round
brilliant marquis oval cushion heart
pear and emerald shaped diamonds all
feature
58 facets the woodpecker finch lives in
the galapagos
islands and uses a cactus spine to drill
holes in wood
epstein killed himself
which of these is the lie
you know i'm gonna have to think i don't
know a whole lot about the finches you
know and about
the diamonds but i'm gonna have to say
jeffrey epstein did not kill himself
that's what i think
okay you got that one right i mean
there's obviously that was a gimmick
obviously it was a given
yeah well ben since you just moved to
florida
which of the following florida man
headlines is the lie
florida man arrested following bust of
python breeding ring behind miami
gordon's waffle house
florida man accused of using kool-aid
packet
to ring up 994 dollars in charges at
walmart
florida man is sole out-of-state
traveler busted
in new york city for breaking quarantine
um i'll go with the third i can't
imagine that nobody else has been busted
for breaking quarantine in new york city
i mean
it seems like i mean even chris cuomo
got a letter didn't he for like not
wearing his mask and stuff so i'll go
with the third one
luckily in chris cuomo's case it was
signed by his brother so it wasn't a
huge deal uh
florida man was the sole out-of-state
traveler in new york city busted for
quarantine
all right damn it ron desantis i know
ronda santos is killing it
the lie actually and i i don't think i
would have gotten this
one right either is that a florida man
was not arrested following the bust of a
python breeding ring behind the miami
gardens waffle house it must have been
behind the jupiter waffle house yeah no
way i would have gotten that one i mean
i thought for sure that was the give me
florida man story okay fine all right
which of the following statements is a
lie in high school
i was on the chess team in high school i
was on model un
in high school i was the editor of my
school newspaper
which is a lie huh you
you weren't the editor of the newspaper
because
you were you're too conservative there's
no way they would let you actually be if
that's the one that like seems like it
should be true because you're the editor
of
news outlets now so i'm gonna say that's
the lie no that's true uh i went to a
jewish school remember i didn't go to a
public school so i went to a jewish
parochial school
so i was the editor of the newspaper
until they tried to thrust upon me a
co-editor at which point as per my usual
arrangement i quit
um but uh the actual the actual lie
there there was no chess team at the
jewish high school
which is shocking that is yeah wow that
uh i would not have expected that i know
are there other things that
that were not there there was no finance
and accounting team at the jewish high
school
and no banking team at jewish high
school and no global conspiracy theme
or weather control team at the jewish
high schools it turns out yeah that's so
yeah not even meteorology club okay well
that's that's fine
so guys i have to i have to leave
because this has been terrible but
who won
[Music]
right wow except i'm still the loser
excited here's the money
wow oh great this is
oh yeah wow look at all of these ones
wow this will buy me a gallon of
gasoline
this is so great we're all going to be
hunter biden tonight ben
well there you have it folks thank you
for tuning in thank you to our sponsors
overhead
mybookie if you enjoyed this video and
you want to see more like it make sure
to like and subscribe
goodbye